we drove to the beach with the mission
of building a full-sized ping-pong table
completely out of sand I think we're
ready in like two hours I think probably
this is already a good start
yeah I'm not sure how playable it will
be but we're gonna find a way to make it
work yeah
[Music]
this is going to be a mission
body or something the three guys with a
bunch of Spades and buckets on a beach
I'm looking at that it's really
suspicious I have to say
and more buckets oh yeah Emma this is
the sand we want oh yeah
[Music]
already starting to regret this idea of
it
world's biggest sand ping pong table
newly wedded couple
[Music]
oh
it's a good shot though getting more and
more optimistic all the time that's nice
it's good to hear that I'd say
we got this we got this
guys we're out here on the beach
building something absolutely ridiculous
so please do us a favor we're trying to
reach 5 million and we're going to make
the world's largest chocolate table
tennis Dragon so please help us out and
subscribe
this reminds me of the ice table I could
do the exact same process
it is it is there has to be tightly
packed
[Music]
does it look like a ping pong table that
yeah no
[Music]
we're making gradual progress hot dogs
stomping the sides to make it more solid
[Music]
building a massive ping pong table out
of sand do you want to help us
and forever
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
good morning
started making here to Adidas I never
thought it made it to me being in L.A
stronger than accept
[Music]
everybody
carving process has begun here
like a big birthday cake
correct
no but it's supposed to be a ping pong
table oh all right there's a lot of
curious people
I watch you guys on YouTube oh you did
no way we have our helper what's your
name Jayden oh that looks delicious what
a soup
oh but now it's looking like a table
[Music]
guys I found a stick that actually works
we have to try if it's airmail solid
okay so we're marking the edges with
some tape it's very primitive
I thought it wasn't work it all comes
down to this the Moment of Truth does
the ball bounce
let's go
oh I actually got it
um
[Music]
oh
it's nearly flat it's ceiling fan
this rally is getting out of hand
to go on the other side
there's nothing left with tape anymore
but all in all it works
subscribe down below